you have been challenged to a coin game
by Qatar the rules are very simple all
you need to do is guess which hand the
coin is in or face the consequences so
go ahead and make your choice I'll give
you three seconds three two one great
now if you went with the left hand then
congratulations you found the coin but
for those of you who went with the right
hand all you have found is a button to
subscribe to the new world review for
regular hunt under content uploaded
straight into your YouTube feed so you
know even though you didn't find the
coin I do think that you aren't the real
winners in this situation hello and
welcome to the new world review your
source for everything anime and manga
and more specifically welcome to the
hunter hunter Ark review where today we
are going to be continuing our journey
through the series by reviewing the
zoldak family arm the zoldak family ark
is the second in series consisting of a
teeny tiny 5 manga chapters as well as 5
anime episodes apiece in both the 1999
and 2011 adaptations before we get too
deeply into that though I should say
that the zoldak family is an unofficial
Ark meaning that these days it is
primarily broken down and isolated by
fans such as myself
however the argument can be made this is
in fact a conclusion to the hundreds
amok or even the true beginning to the
heavens arena rock however personally I
prefer to keep it separate because it
deals with a particular story at a
particular location that is highly
removed from its neighbouring arcs and I
think that despite its short nature it
is better discussed in an individual
context but as for the general premise
following the events of the hunter exam
gonk Rebecca and Leo do set off after
Kilowog who has retreated to his home on
kukuda Mountain after his encounter with
illumi very basic promise set up almost
as one would think to be something of a
rescue Ark however in what would turn
out to be classic hunter hunter what we
get is entirely different and probably
infinitely more satisfying the zoldak
family ark in my mind is a masterpiece
of short form storytelling it gets in
and out making efficient and powerful
use of every single panel it takes up
and manages to introduce a plethora of
new characters for us to be excited
about going forward into the story thus
expanding the world and the first group
who needs to talk about are obviously
the titular Zeltiq family so at this
point when I was going through hunter
hunter killer was one of my favorite
characters in the series and it was a
real treat to see the twisted family he
came from because firstly I loved the
concept that the zoldak family are
essentially celebrity assassins
so that you can even take a bus tour
right up to their front gate kind of
weird subversion of ideas that I really
enjoy storytelling giving characters
naturally opposing quirks like having a
profession that requires the utmost
secrecy while at the same time being
globally famous simply due to said
profession and every member of the
Tzadik family we are introduced to
during this arc is very much larger than
life with the exception of maybe Carter
who doesn't get to do a lot of this
stage except stare creepily but you know
they have a real Addams Family dynamic
going on here because they live such
twisted lives but it makes them happy I
mean for example stuff like kikyo being
such a proud mother of kilwa because he
gave her a cold death glare well one of
my favorite moments of comedy during the
arc where kilowatt is being tortured by
Maliki and he wakes up and just
genuinely says good morning Maliki as if
this is some sort of mundane event which
I guess it really is for kilowatt and
that makes it really fun to read because
despite the perceived seriousness of
what's going on things are always kept
pretty light-hearted and adventurous all
the way through the family member who
definitely intrigued me most at this
stage though was definitely Xena he had
this wonderful air of authority about
him likes of which I don't think even
Silva was able to exude at this point
but at the same time he also had a
comical quality which was on display
when he was chastising Maliki but
basically I just wanted more from this
entire family and I would gladly read a
watch an entire series centered around
the daily life of the zoldak estate but
these five chapters don't just do a
great job of introducing this family but
also their extended employees which
carry a similar sense of intrigue the
obvious one to mention would be Cocteau
and in fact his part in the story is
probably the most memorable event of the
entire arc but he gets gone crap occur
and the Oreo to take part in his coin
game and this sequence deserves a
particular shout-out in regards to its
adaptation in the 2011 anime as well
it's a fairly simple technique but the
way they animated his movements really
conveyed this profound sense of speed
and in my opinion really Trump the manga
presentation of the coin game has all
good anime adaptation should I guess
what I love about the original manga
though is the way that gato was drawn he
has this wonderfully simple design that
often obscures his eyes and leaves his
mouth as nothing but a short horizontal
line it really effectively conveys his
stoic nature and I think a lot of that
wonderful sleek look gets a bit lost in
the anime which obviously elects twenty
tailed to his facial features in order
to match the rest of the world style
that they had set up at that point but
something else that I love about gato is
the retrospective view I have on
going back on the zoldak family ark it
really is like a tale of two father
figures with God to being so
overprotective of kilowatt while silver
is much more willing to allow kilowatt
to have his freedom for the time being
with very few questions asked and so
gato fulfills that much more traditional
parental role and I mean just think of
it this way gone is kind of like a
teenage boy who has come over to pick
Gatos child-killer
up for a date and so gato does the
traditional father thing of striking
fear into gone to make sure that he
doesn't hurt his precious kilowatt going
unto test him and then eventually
approving of Kilis choices in life
another character who really struck me
was canary there because she has one of
my favorite designs in Hunter hunter I
mean she just looks so damn cool and her
fighting style with the cane is a
pleasure to watch more canary is always
a welcome feature and once again this is
where the 2011 anime excelled as it
decided to animate her conflict with the
blacklist hunters when she was a mere 10
years old they also added a really fun
section where canary uses the rhythm
echo technique the kilowatt invoked
during the hunter exam arc which was a
nice touch because it was able to
solidify a relationship between her and
kilowatt as they even showed him
demonstrating the ability to canary and
it just gave the two a nice bond and
made the eventual moments where Gomberg
through to her mentally all the more
powerful
speaking of zoldak family out gone is
very much peaked shown and gone in
Hunter hunter another of the most
memorable moments of the arc is when he
is just continuously taking a beating
from canary refusing to fight back but
getting up over and over again
early to be meant for the came in face
it was actually very reminiscent of his
fight against Hanzo during the hunter
exam showing us the gold special ability
really is more about being able to charm
and change the thinking of those around
him moreover this time around the audio
and karateka just stood there because
they had already seen this ability in
effect once before plus I'm sure they
all felt very similarly to gone and knew
that this was really the only course of
action possible still it was nice to see
that evolution from the two of them
because when gone pulled this crap again
Tonto they were both completely aghast I
guess I should also point out that the
zoldak family ark would be the last time
that we see this group of characters
together in standard Chernin formation
which is kind of sad to think about in
retrospect I really enjoyed the gone
they Oreo tropica and Kilowog
combination and I think that together
they are pretty much an unbeatable team
at any task but I also understand that
Takashi had different and grand visions
for the immediate future of hunter
hunter at this point although it is a
particular shame thinking of Leo do
the zoldak family ark made him look
pretty damn cool I mean in the manga we
saw him opening the first testing gate
all on his own and zebra even mentioned
that he was able to open the second as
well something which gone and karappa
cthis point was seemingly not able to do
on their own so it would seem that li
aria was being set up as potentially the
physically strongest main protagonist
while I mean bar and killer of course
but for whatever reason toga she did
take this weird time to highlight Leora
possibly because of how neglected his
combative aspect was during the hunter
exam but at the same time in the end he
did decide not to pursue that route with
his character so the Tzadik family ark
would slay REO in this weird sort of
halfway point of relevance and the final
character I want to give specific
mention to is that of zebra this guy was
a pretty charming old man type of
character who was very easy to get on
board with but he also provided what was
one of our first glimpses of nen and I
say one of because there were definite
moments in the hunter exam when nan was
applied but this was a very obvious shot
of him emanating aura which would become
some great foreshadowing for the power
system to be introduced immediately
during the next dock but really as I
mentioned before the zoldak family aqua
is a wonderful subversion of Shonen
expectations still being fairly early on
in series I had no high expectations of
hunt hunter at this point and I was 100%
convinced that this arc was going to
follow the very standard beats and those
beats in this case would be the setup
and implementation of a rescue on you
know Kilwa being imprisoned by his own
family and then Gong Karaka and the REO
had to barge in and face a series of
escalating enemies including monsters
Butler's and eventually the zoldak
family members themselves culminating in
a dramatic battle with whoever the head
of the family was in order to add killer
back into the group once and for all and
I could not be more glad that that did
not come to fruition in fact not only
did none of that action happen but the
moment kilowatt was returned the group
just split up and went their separate
ways
it really was unexpected in every facet
for me and I think that this point in
hunt hunter is what oh gosh II made a
conscious decision that he did not want
to make another you haka sure and to
have the series start to take on its own
identity and it was surprisingly
refreshing the sock essentially ended
with a heart-to-heart between kilowatt
and silver it sure that Honda Honda had
a sense of maturity that I don't think
any of its contemporaries came close to
at the time of publication
under anta was willing to pursue
solutions that mimicked a more
real-world scenario which in this case
might seem like it's simplified the arc
overall
but it would go on to make the series
itself far more complex and
unpredictable so in some ways the zoldak
family arc acts as a bit of a rebirth to
the series and the beginning of a truly
unique story and that pretty much does
it for this review of the zoldak family
arc if you enjoyed this video on the
content this channel produced in general
then please do consider donating to the
new worldview patreon because the
support of all of you amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
for this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my desk
or server where a wide array of
shenanigan takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with your
thoughts on the zoldak family arc this
has been the new world review and I'll
see you next time just watched code
geass I felt the plots Janke was vital
in setting the tone of its finale it's a
great anime but I couldn't recommend it
to anyone with a clear conscience
thoughts on Code Geass
all right Kirk yes is a bit of a tricky
one because there's a lot of it that I
just plain love but a bunch of it that I
really don't luckily those two feelings
can very much be separated by season I
personally think that the first season
of code geass is pure brilliance and it
had me hooked the entire way in fact the
finale of it was one of the more
exciting moments of my anime watching
childhood especially due to the
circumstances around producing it
because the series went on hiatus for a
couple of months before showing the
final two episodes as part of a one-hour
broadcast and those two episodes also
have a special opening my favorite Code
Geass opening by far being here Tommy no
tsubasa which I still listen to to this
day however I think the Tizen 2 brought
a lot of problems with it and did not
even come close to effectively closing
out this world there were a lot of new
characters introduced like Rolo and the
knights of the round that I never talked
to and I think that's a shame because
every character in season 1 had me
compelled yes even people like mal or
Nina a lot of the r2 exclusive
characters were superfluous though and
it just wasn't as much fun to watch
tweak tweak as r1 was with that said I
would always recommend courteous to
anybody interested in the anime medium
it's a solid series and I find that most
fans aren't is
pickies mean regards to season 2 so yeah
go for it
I will say that I haven't seen the new
movie yet Lelouch of the resurrection so
if you have then let me know what your
thoughts are in the comments below